[Music]
no featured event of the evening
as tonight
being presented boxing afternoon
[Music]
these are fighting words better give me
that respect that I
did have them sipping moving like a tire
swerve out here acting bad thank you
Michael Jackson even got his winning
only homie Kevin you a phony homie now
you owe me action have em thinking Tony
Toni Toni Braxton and they all want to
talk for attention but the fame only
lasts for an instant mama got hands
doing bread for the tension imma leave
them red you can dance to Redemption
foreign
[Music]
good
you hear me
boy you have no idea all the stuff that
I was doing let me know if you can hear
me
put a one in the chat if you can hear me
all right
fives was good was good fun it's my dude
everybody can hear so everything coming
in clear
good good yo this is my son
Brandon say what's up your face is get
covered by the mic all right yeah they
go Kayla plant
making the drinks right now um right now
making uh hypnotic
oh
oh pink lemonade jump off
um so everybody be sipping on something
running a little bit late moving as fast
as possible had a problem with Discord
ordered the fight on Xbox for the wife
and family to watch and um we're having
a problem with that right now everybody
say hey Brandon what's up so um
I'll be right back give me a couple of
seconds while I finish these drinks and
make sure this fight is on for everybody
else
biggest fight
of the early half of the year to be
honest with you this is probably one of
the biggest fights right now
um so everybody checking share this out
give me a couple of seconds we got 24
watching we just saw Gabe Rosado lose uh
not surprising all right we already knew
that Gabe was in it for a check but um
we got everybody showing up right now
Mike Tyson right now Dr J everybody let
me go make these drinks
that's gonna be crazy
a huge opportunity for The Undefeated
Cuban power
nine professional fight he's 8-0 with
seven Kos and he takes
who took this fight on 10 days note
it for 12 rounds
100 and
88 pounds
Jr
we'll fans at this time please
please to the ring first here is the
Challenger from Brazil ranked the number
six Super middleweight in the world
please welcome
foreign
I think
inside the room
all right
right here right here right here
oh
he said Leonard that'll be just a
mouthpiece for Al there's a fight not
acting like he's capacity as TMP yep
that's what 31 watching let's get those
likes up um
let me see let me see
right now who we got going on over here
we got two fights before the main event
on two fights before the main event
let me run over here
save the stream welcome to your attic
did that yeah addict did that
he ain't promoting by tmb I'll be in the
loop for a minute but it's the David's
still affiliated with TMT yeah all right
so
he's definitely still affiliated with um
Al Haymon and um he has his own
promotional company so how that goes
take Davis uh promotional T TD
D is something like that
he has his own promotional so with his
phone promotional they push the fight
that way right so they go through the
tank and so does Ryan Garcia
what up good peoples
all right I'm running over here I gotta
put the fight on for everybody inside
the Next Room
because I got the fight running here got
the fight running over there I got a
do magic right now give me a couple of
seconds
he just
the right trajectory
[Music]
35 years of age
presents the co-main event of the
evening and a world attraction brought
to you by GTD promotions tgb promotions
Golden Boy promotions and Showtime
pay-per-views
attendance
from Nevada Patricia Morse German and
from Oklahoma David Sutherland
Ruiz
Museum
owns
Gucci
what's that
what you talking about
I don't know
ring is the defending world of Champions
hiding out of the blue Corner wearing
white trunks with multi-colored trim
fighting out of Minneapolis Minnesota by
way of
see seven and three quarter pounds he is
undefeated in his campaign to the
professional ranks number 67.
tonight making his Las Vegas debut and
the fifth defense of his title here is
the undefeated and defending WBA super
Junior you can talk to them
once again our referee in charge
I know this is kind of new to me
what's up peoples
wings and drinks definitely a fight
who I got on this fight who I got on
this fight I'm going on Garcia
heavy on it actually I'm like
super super Garcia fan
I feel like I don't know I feel like I
feel like they're both really really
talented and they both have they both
have really good speed and really good
power but where they round it out more I
feel like Garcia's rounded outboarders
all right yo what's your call is right
there at movie star there you go cheers
try that
that's what we sipping on
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah you already know
I'm impeccable with the drink impeccable
with the drinks all right so got the
fight over there got the fight over here
fight is popping we popping
yo somebody said Dr carrier said who
need King you you turn on me that quick
y'all get new blood and turn on me that
quick y'all out of control all right how
we got we got 30 watching all right so
check it out
we've been looking for this fight for a
minute right
he I told you he's the reason why I just
said the hell would have let my beard go
gray when you got a handsome kid like
that who the hell needs to be walking
around here trying to you know what am I
trying to get I let him scoop up
everybody I ain't trying to scoop up
nobody I got mine
all right so all right
we've been looking for this fight for a
minute y'all know we've been looking for
this fight for a minute I never thought
they was going to actually get a chance
to fight I thought honestly that it
would be a duck game right
um
and it's not
we here so we sort of weigh in here's
the controversy we had two weigh-ins
right yeah the first way in was the the
they both came in under the 136. this is
the catch-weight fight right now they
had the day of right oh boy is about to
get knocked out Morel is about to knock
out Flaco right now all right so
they had the day of weigh-in they
weighed in today of fight and it can be
more than 146 they both weighed in under
146 Ryan Raiden at 144 and tank weighed
in at 141. Morel is about to knock out
uh Flacco right now uh he hit him with
an uppercut uh the referee is breaking
them up right now this is round number
one all right so right there Flacco's
throwing a crazy jab and he's um
stalking I mean um Morrell head over to
uppercut Flacco was out cold round one
silver fights over let's get going let's
get to this main event as fast as
possible
let us know King what's up Brandon what
you sipping on bro all right all right
so
this is a special margarita mix right
and uh this is a strawberry margarita
made with strawberry uh lemonade
you know the BJ's Costco kind you know
what you do and
um I put hypnotic inside
so yeah so you got a margarita with
hypnotic yeah it is what it is
yes yes yes that was a good fight Morel
definitely did his thing boy still
stretched out on the canvas hurting yeah
that that that that uppercut's kind of
stinky he he gave him the stinky Pinky
post right no he came watch you're gonna
see it it's gonna be an uppercut it's a
slash replica watch
it's a stepping
money
Morel he's Dominican right Cuban he
Cuban all right yeah
I knew he was Caribbean
you got that Caribbean face you
definitely want all the problems you can
see it in his face yeah trying to get
paid this is this is the stage where
everybody wants to get paid all right so
next month we got Haney versus
lomachenko
baby can't stand it it's gonna get stink
then we have T.O versus Josh that's
crazy in June but also in June from what
I hear from what a little birdie telling
me we're gonna have uh Crawford versus
Spence
let's go yeah he out cold he out cold
safer he is out cold you want to talk
about a cold-blooded knockout first
round This Is How We Do sorry I couldn't
get the haircut man I was doing so much
I ran around so much today I was Upstate
New York downstate New York moving all
around had to prepare for my son five
minutes before we even got here I had to
run out and go grab a pizza ah you know
cause you gotta eat man you gotta eat
strong young man eat gotta eat man gotta
make sure you got food in his belly plus
you know his young lady's hair so you
know make sure that they they right you
know got their drinks on Swap
all right so the reason why they taking
so long with this they did not expect
Morrell to knock them out in the first
round
so they're gonna keep this here for as
long as possible to try to give you a
six round feel right and that way they
can probably catch up with time until
tank take a little bit longer coming out
tell Ryan take a little bit longer
coming out because remember the fighters
is in the back getting warmed up
all right so I think at this time
they're supposed to be probably in the
middle of hand wrapping because I think
that was the the this was the the last
fight before the main it can't be it's
too early it's too early they got one
more yeah they should have one more who
text me
okay
yeah yeah
all right shout out with Jason with the
two dollars a three dollar Super Chat
let's go champ chill champ chill facts
oh see told you look look watch watch
watched up again Boop told you what I
told you it was see now now he's gonna
give him this the next the same one he's
gonna give it to him when he catches him
up against the Rope
all right he gave him a couple of he
gave him the standing eight right there
it's the uppercut
because his defense is is straga look
you see how he put his hands
he went around his guard and he just
leaped him because he knew he was weak
and he was off balance so he was able to
do so
throw the jab on them and look he's
setting up in Southport and Orthodox you
just saw him right there right go into
Southport
all right and this is that's the first
knock down still
we doing the recap of the Watchman
caller
you got that yeah that right hook though
yeah
let me see damn I missed it that was the
they showed a second knockout now it was
the right hook yeah I could have sworn
it was the uppercut the Right Hook was
the last one that put them down you
right now I want to see what set it up
because I believe it was the uppercut to
put his head in the air
all right
right here
see
oh left hook oh oh it was a left
no he's Orthodox right there
hey it was right yeah he's right it was
yeah his right hook yeah he's right see
that's why you're here
that's why you got a son that's right
here
so
ever since he was young I was taking him
to the boxing gym right and um right now
I'm trying to get him and his other two
brothers and take them all to the boxing
gym and you know work out as a family uh
we got 46 watching that's what's up we
got 15 likes come on if you don't like
it come on stop playing man you like me
why you don't like me why I'm not your
favorite oh I'm not your favorite make
me a favor stop playing like me
I mean the way I feel about both the way
I feel about uh right now he can't fight
he has a lot of like he has a lot of
flaws but this is round one he was
feeling them out yeah round one
I feel like that's what it was he took
advantage that they was filling each
other out to lose that weight that
height he was the younger stronger
faster dude he did what he was supposed
to do he came in and did what he's I
can't take nothing away from Morrell he
he walked in there thinking it was
control
oh he thought at least he was gonna get
five six rounds on this belt now a young
boy jumped on his back I would like to
see Morel versus boots
anybody down with Morel versus boots I
would love to see Morel versus boots but
we're not gonna get that right now
because boots is like hair and Morel is
like right here so we're gonna get Morel
probably um getting a couple more fights
on this belt before we even worry about
boots boots is worrying about title
fights
and you know Morel is worrying about
relevance trying to you know make a name
for herself make everybody see it I like
the the
hoodie
all right
so let me see
we're like Brandon stream
hey yo and you put the little eyes
if he wasn't such a cool dude yeah
yeah ham is there farms is there you're
fine so you got funds what up Charlie
what's good
fly guard what's good
Charles was good Don was good Killian
Brown that's my dude Killian Brown is
always around that's what's up
tsws
he can't Best Stop Finance wings and
drinks there we go
Rico what's good
check in everybody check in there we go
there we go
Troy attic who won oh with the morel
fight Morel one Morel uh knock Flaco out
boom bang
it's disgusting
yeah two minutes and two and 52 seconds
I guess
ridiculous
that's a great fight to me yeah I mean
they're going to get your check yeah to
get that check that's what that was two
minutes right there get a good check for
two minutes
yeah training camp was worth it all that
work that you put in was worth it let me
see
who won what do you think about Tyson
Fury versus Andrew Ruiz possibly July
um me and my wife was talking about that
earlier Tyson Fury versus Andy Louise
um I think Tyson is Too Tall too strong
too too long pulse
um and has boxing IQ is way too high for
Andy Ruiz I think Andy Ruiz doesn't get
past the jab doesn't get past the the
weight that Tyson to put on him his fast
hands can't help him if he can't cut
distance and Andy has fast hands but
slow feet that's the problem that's the
same problem that you're gonna have
tonight with Garcia Garcia has fast
hands but slow feet he has to plant to
throw the hook
but so he can also throw the hook off
the pivot right so you have Fighters
that if if they don't have fast hands
and fast feet
they can't cut distance the difference
between uh Garcia tonight and Andy Ruiz
Andy Louise is the shorter fighter that
has to cut distance he's probably the
more explosive fighter but he has to get
in to to use his advantages you're not
getting in on Tyson Fury Tyson Fury is
going to keep him at distance and he's
going to box some educational lives like
that jab is going to take him to school
gonna work them and that right hand
gonna be something serious on them
um honestly that's not a good fight
that's not a fight that I want to see
but it's not gonna be a fun fight it's
not it's gonna be a sloppy boring nasty
fight with uh Andrew Ruiz either
quitting on his stool or getting stopped
by TKO if he get Cuts if he get Cuts he
might as well forget it let me see what
else
what's up King but equals in the house
that's what's up what up what up there's
what's good dang I missed it bro I just
got home
that's what's up I'm still gutter Fury
you sick didn't get to make it happen
that fight didn't happen because of
scheduling wise right where lomachenko
left the Ukraine and came back and and
got out of the fight or whatever
usek stayed a little bit longer and his
political ties and stuff like that you
know this is this is boxing he has all
the belts
I wouldn't be quick to jump in the ring
with Tyson Fury if I'm at uh uh height
weight uh size disadvantage usick is
great he has good hand speed and good
foot speed and he moves like a ballerina
in the ring
can he cut the distance on Fury he
doesn't have the power I think to cut
the distance uh so he has to get time
and I don't think you're able to time
Tyson Fury he's a very hard nut to crack
pause so yeah because the way Tyson
fights he's like he's tight but sloppy
yeah it's like weird he's Slinky like
his body yeah he fight like his body
right so it's kind of like it's one is
going to be hard to get past the job
and then that right hand is just gonna
be a hammer behind it and the uppercuts
and he throws those up because yeah
because he jiggled when he wiggles
y'all seen Garcia and tank put the whole
fight purse on the line okay I think
that's real let me let me let me explain
that to you
um that's not real yeah
yeah it was the Heat of the Moment right
there yeah [__] online your mom's
just telling me right she was like why
would he do that where where's his
Corner who's I said babe that's not real
that's all the cell stuff um
remember Garcia has to pay people
right he's not fighting uh for himself
he's fighting for everybody that's in
his Camp how a check Works in for boxes
boxes get the check they have to pay the
gym they have to pay everybody else's uh
that that's working for him cutting
excuse me cut man
team everything
the fighter gets the shorter than the
stick even though he does the main work
he's the talent
because he pays everybody he cannot bet
his purse so if he gets 10 million
dollars he can't say yeah tank 10
million dollars win to take all no
that's nice it sounds nice they used to
do stuff like that back in the days
that's not factual that's not on the
line but what what um Ryan Garcia was
trying to say was everything is on the
line anyway bro like he who wins this
fight right now is at the head of the
pack I don't think the loser of this
fight even if they lose in dramatic
devastating fashion I don't think the
loser of this fight falls to the end of
the line I just think the loser of this
fight Falls to number two and number one
will be the head of the the the little
guys the 135 the 140 and under dudes
like Devin Haney even though he's
um unified uh champion and he holds all
the belts Devin Haney versus lomachenko
they will be fighting for a hard third
because you know right now if you pick
any one of those two fighters let's say
lomachenko beats uh Devin Haney
he the winner of this is above
lomochenko
right going in as a betting favorite so
and and if it's uh you know Javonte uh
wins and Dave and um Haney wins still
Haney is not going to be the Baton
favorite you got to go buy who's going
to be the betting favorite where the
money is perceived you know uh Vegas
don't play
you know tank tank is a whole monster
he's a whole monster this is gonna be
crazy King David when are we playing
fortnite together brother yo I'm on all
the time you know that just hit me up
every time I get your messages though
I'll be getting your messages like at 11
o'clock at night when I'm almost dead
asleep
it's just for sure that's right this oh
there was on some more pro wrestling
promo yup hello everyone what up what up
Kate thanks for the explanation I got
you what you think about Wilder captain
again that he'll kill Fury in four
fights man Fury terrorized some of the
previous three
the only person on this planet that can
beat Tyson Furious Deontay Wilder
you saw how those three fights went
right first fight Deontay Wilder I he
had to lose because you don't get the
other two fights if he beats him and
they count them out they count while
they're out I mean uh uh Fury out when
he got knocked out because he got
knocked out but if they count him out
and don't give him the Long Count
do you think wilda goes back and fight
this madman never again
so you get the next fight the next fight
Deontay Wilder was feeling himself he
comes out wearing all this stuff I don't
care what that is whatever excuses that
he made Tyson Fury was cheating
throughout all three fights here so what
it what what Tyson Fury tells you stop
me whatever the problem is you stop me
all right so he didn't stop him he had
his hand down and his glove I don't care
you lost he got beat around the bushes
all of those all of those fights
hands put on him but wilda has one thing
that nobody in the heavyweight division
has nobody has what Wilder has he has a
punch that'll separates your body from
your soul
like you ever get hit so hard that your
your soul step out your body and say bro
he's fighting with divine intervention
like just he has divine intervention
punches like to make you say oh God
yo what's going on melies
um
so yeah I honestly I think Tyson Fury
retires undefeated
I honestly think so because if if the
Hitman Deontay Wilder couldn't take him
out and he had numerous chances every
and every time he hits Tyson Fury flush
Tyson through he hits that ground and he
gets up or he gets wobbly he you don't
you have never seen nobody else do that
to Tyson Fury right so obviously number
two heavyweight in the world has to be
Deontay Wilder right the problem with
Deontay Wilder he took so much
punishment we don't know what's up
the black Harry Potter with the 10 super
chat just dropping in to honor the king
thanks for the content my IOP pillow was
something I never knew I needed it's
fire yo
I'm so happy seeing that all you guys
that supported us got your pillows I am
so happy that the pillows is coming
through anybody that need any pillows go
to Volari uh go to the website uh click
on the IOP promotion I think it's
um a lord 15 is the 15 that you get off
on getting our pillows
when you have it on
you never knew you needed it until you
got it and when you get it you're gonna
be like oh my God this is the wildest
thing ever let me move this mic so they
can see your face
yeah my boy handsome boy now we're gonna
we're gonna sit here and not show his
face my boy handsome boy
and I I hey
play my joystick don't come for him
you got solved don't come for him let me
see who this in here see Mac wild is the
secret boss in the video game if he
touches you once the game's over fact
though
if while the Deontay Wilder fights
Anthony Joshua Wilder destroys Joshua
yeah but so what
they let's let's get the fight right get
so these two fighters where else they
going they know that the top boss is
Tyson Fury we know AJ gonna get
destroyed we we're tired of seeing AJ
eek out of fights and fight Deontay
Wilder you don't want that Soul
snatching he don't want the soul snatch
because he know the snow snatch once the
soul come out of his body we saw what
Andy Weezer doing and he was able to box
Andy the next fight
who hits all the king while the uh or
better beef Wilder
his knockout ratio is second to none
his knockout ratio is better than Mike
Tyson's better than George Foreman's
his knockout ratio is something sick
insane
he touching you going to sleep
the fact that the pillow is the best
investment for my posture facts that's
true thank you Darth Raven and pause
it's king with here yo shut up they said
That's you with me
yo y'all highly disrespectful and
unconscionable I really don't like you
dudes right now we got 74 watching let's
go get those likes up 35 on the stream
fighting race start soon baby
hey everybody go get that Focus y'all
know what that is I'm gonna need this
tomorrow to focus on that podcast you
know what it is to keep your boy fresh
and ready but right now
my man cuphead is here
ah compared with the prediction
cuphead what
who who you got
what company
oh
cuphead said it's going to be a dramatic
knockout by hook up eh
he said obviously tank
he said 10th round tank
TKO they're gonna throw in the towel on
Ryan Ryan gonna be screaming help help
and they just gonna fall out like oh and
he gonna look at the camera like
thank God I ain't bet my purse
I got Ryan Garcia winning
who's left to fight tonight I think it's
one more fight before the main all right
so
here's the thing
Ryan Garcia is taller
younger
faster
heavier
all that [__] [__] matter right
best defense will go to tank
he has fast hands and fast feet Ryan has
fast Hands slow feet
so that means his opponents always get a
chance to get on his chest Ryan has been
down before
right so yeah we'll see but the problem
with that Luke Campbell ain't ain't the
dude the feather fisted dude that you
want to sit there and be like oh yeah
man yeah because if he knock you down
the question is
what's gonna happen when tank put them
hands on he put the Mets on you all
right so we say what happens when tank
put the Mets on you
but the thing is
maybe he was taking Luke for granted
maybe he thought Luke could hurt him
and those punches That You Don't See
hurt so maybe Garcia was just like you
know I'ma walk to this dude he wasn't
giving Luke his respect right we know he
gonna give tank his respect of course
hmm
tank is always losing a lot of times in
his fights and he catches a dude with
that bang and his body just don't act
right like your boy the last Garcia he
fought I didn't even have to change the
title inside my joint the last Garcia he
fought He Turned the Lights Off in his
head he couldn't see out his eyes he
said oh my God he got hit in the top of
his head the Lights Went Out the
Dominican though oh my God
I can't see
shut the fight off
I think the next fight is is one fight
away
nah I think he is okay I think I think
because you like his you like how he
looks it's not about the look it's not
about the look it's supposed to speed
all right the speed even if it's hand
speed the hand speed is what beat speed
what beats speed because I know yeah but
what beats speed time
all right so who got better timer you're
gonna say Javonte
who got better timing what it's like
less time for his arms all right all
right when he fought roley
okay yeah no all right rolly was in it
to win it roly had him up against the
ropes rolly was coming in what he did
timed him
yeah all right when he shut the lights
out on on Garcia what did he do
that was time timing that was timing
yeah I don't know when he he timed him
with the hand with that right I called
it on stream he caught him with that
so yeah but you you you you he was
setting that up the whole time exactly
the whole time but you got to time him
right Ryan's not gonna see that
see that I don't know you think Ryan's
not gonna see that
I don't know
that's why we're here
so this is this is good this is always
good it's always good to have an
opposing view because I'm I'm a fanboy
of uh tank Davis but I love Ryan Garcia
like if you want to get a fighter if you
if Ryan if you making a fighter he's a
promoter's dream
fast hands handsome tall picture poster
perfect that's right he can he gonna do
Dolce Gabbana he could do whatever we
gonna make money Calvin Klein Put Some
Calvin Kleins and Versace on this boy
let's go let's get the the Gucci
slippers on this kid let's get this
money
so yeah on that aspect that's why he got
so many Instagram followers
but if he's so good
how come he has a four foot title yeah
um maybe and all the fights that he did
have he had him available in front of
him but oh boy you didn't take none of
them what happened why
maybe because you wanted you want a tank
was it that way take was off in him
earlier
but I think I think I think the the
contract wasn't looking right
is that not the case is that not always
the case uh listen I'm I'ma say this I'm
not gonna call him a duck right
I'ma say he strategically picked the
individuals that he needed to pick to
get to the space that he's at I think he
has no place to run nowhere to hide no
place to run no [__] huh no I think
it's more e strategically picked who he
wanted to fight to get to where he
wanted to be and now he's here does that
help you uh gain experience
I mean not necessarily no no you don't
see the experience okay you don't gain
the experience you're right you're right
but now what about uh what's what's this
guy's name Julio Cesar Chavez what was
he 86 or no for a whole bunch of cab
drivers but not all of those fights was
cab drivers you can't say magic you
can't say magic Taylor was a cab driver
not all of them but the cab drivers how
much experience is that that's a ton of
experience is that really yeah exactly
you're running through like this okay
all right all right all right look look
at who you can't you uh
you take one of the greats the lion the
kuya Khan you you gonna really go to the
lion you're gonna really go there you're
gonna do that you're gonna put them
boys this boy he would hope to afford as
many cab drivers as this dude he needs
to fight right right so right now Ryan
right now he's there with Dan Goosen
right what I'm seeing is and okay let me
tell you the problem with Ryan's um
setup we got Eddie ugly right now yeah
his shorts is ugly but he needs that job
that he's taking right now it's like
super wide and and it's slow everything
is wide he's opening everything up all
right so this is the problem they told
him to change his jab that jab that he's
throwing that's not the jab that you've
been seeing from the gym all right
he don't look at this he's trying to
fight a short fighter today the problem
is what you saw right there where all
his punches was oh
where's tank down he's been training his
whole training camp and I've been
watching it somebody big and strong
punching up
he hasn't been punching down today he's
going to be punching down on a tank
that's going to be closing distance
tank I mean listen
he should be nervous
he should be nervous he should be
absolutely terrified right now because
if you're not afraid you're not cautious
if you're not cautious you're gonna get
caught by something he should be
everything he should feel every emotion
right now actually I would have told him
take the the what you call us out and
I'ma cry a little bit I'm gonna cry I'm
gonna get a little tear out could y'all
get out of here for a second I'm gonna
get a tear out
see
tank looking good right there
right see that yeah he's working for the
body yeah uh-huh I think he want to
knock him out with a left hook but even
though he's Southpaw which is crazy all
right so we got 88 watching we got 45
likes let's go blocks black boxing King
tank Davis built up the fight by not
taking by not taking it so early this is
true
I think Ryan going early under seven
Ryan finishes people in the first few
rounds if he doesn't think we'll have
the upper hand at the end rounds but
Ryan will win okay yo David he backs up
incorrectly too
that part
I'm talking about Ryan Ryan step back
Ryan footwork the problem with Ryan
is his feet
he he stands like
with both his feet right parallel to
each other
yeah and also the problem with Ryan is
his getaway
his head his chin is in the air he
throws his head back his chin is always
up now the only person that I know that
was able to get away with that and and
in boxing history has been Muhammad Ali
sure right and Muhammad Ali does it when
he's looking at you like his chin is up
but it's down and he's looking at you so
right he's trying to see what you're
doing because he as soon as you miss
that inch over the top right and he's
gonna hit you with that overhand that's
crazy
Davis all day and the straight back he
doesn't pivot thank you
yeah I'm glad you yo Dolph man what's up
man you trying to take my job he don't
pivot he don't pivot at all
when you're on the line and somebody's
coming in on you and they got you at a
disadvantage if you hunker down you got
to either pivot to your left or to your
right right depending on what your
control hand is so if your control hand
is your right hand which is here and you
catch it you're gonna pivot to your
right right to give him the left hook
off the top if your control hand is to
your left you're gonna guide them this
way and push them while you go to your
left and you can catch him with the
right or you can bring the left off the
hand off the outstretched hand
it's a lot of things that you want to do
when you're being pursued I think that
it should have been he his training cap
should have been more on Pursuit and
defend and also pursue and defend
somebody that's lower than him I've seen
him doing a lot of countering up a lot
of punching up uh is that to keep his
hands from getting tired during training
during training camp I don't know
let's go King with us Alpha
boxing royalty in the house George
Foreman 2 was good shout out to my man's
Kings what's going on
you we you wait Legend facts what's good
we got 93 watching we about to bust a
hundred pause let's bust a hundred
together let's get that share it out to
everybody we got Sugar Ray Leonard over
here
ah man and Manny Manny Pacquiao they're
gonna start talking to the crowd because
uh Morel wasn't supposed to knock out
your boy that early
spectacular yeah yeah he he did a
definite good service to us all here
oh I gotta um head up the chat
uh
yo
let me uh tweet this out
oh
I'm texting Cog right now
I'm excited
um
let me see oh okay what's up Gabe AKA
Cali kid 619 with the two dollar Super
Chat King David is King on King David
thank you brother blessings thank you
thank you thank you
oh did y'all get a chance to see the
last r r with the King this week on on
with the Lords this week on RNR I saw
um the Pope's Exorcist and I saw air the
Michael Jordan movie
yeah yeah it's this that I'm not a
Michael Jordan fan never been a Scottie
Pippen fan my whole life uh never I
never could stand Michael Jordan after
watching that movie I got a deeper
respect for Michael Jordan and the stuff
that he brought to the table
um and my my thoughts was a whole bunch
of other stuff on Michael Jordan y'all
after this movie he probably is the
greatest
um to to do it because of what he was
coming into where he was going with it
it's absolutely nuts but go go check out
the last r with the uh with the Lord's
RNR with the Lord's this
um Tuesday is gonna be dope I Gotta Give
attic a movie it was a movie that um I
was on the game of circle today with
everborn and chaosanti with um with uh
silent Cipher
it's dope dope show check it out
everyone said something let me see King
if Ryan win what will happen to his
career and also if tank wins what's next
of the new uh Fight Night Champion no
he's gonna be on that um what's that
Undisputed that that game yeah
um if Ryan wins
Ryan goes up to 140 tanks has the
rematch they have a rematch they're
gonna have a regardless we lose the draw
they're gonna have a rematch this money
here you don't have celebrities of this
fashion out right now this is this is a
super fight super fight right no belt on
the line but these dudes are doing it
name and fame let's go this is the name
this is the glory this is a surprise
fighting at this finest you got
everybody out here y'all talk to talk
it's time to walk the walk
Ryan wins they're gonna have a rematch
tank wins they're going to have a
rematch where they go from the rematch
we don't know but they will have a
rematch
if tank wins
he might ease up on some of the stuff
with the with the weight on uh Ryan
Garcia for the next fight uh because it
was a lot of stipulations here
re-hydration Clauses and stuff like that
if Garcia wins not at this fight the
next fight that they have is going to be
at 140 some pounds all right know that
that that's exactly what's going to
happen all right so let me see yeah
they're both undefeated what will happen
if one wins okay they gave you that
you're gonna watch Evil Dead rise yes
sir
Ben Affleck undefeated underrated
director
no
what a guy does is
he gets his best friend his best friend
is Matt Damon
those two together is Magic like they
work off each other so well their magic
I recommend that movie to go see it
because of those two Matt Damon is a
animal as an actor he can be anything
he's like like he's like the Bruce Lee
of acting be water and he will mold
himself to whatever role it is to fit
that role he has been everything that's
Jason Bourne
understand that he played GoldenEye he
did the James Bond thing Spencer put 20K
on tank of course he did a lot of dudes
just putting this money out here you
know hey shout out to Houston's finest
you know
yeah I got Ryan Garcia the third round
KO let's go Jake Paul gonna lose all his
bread he's still losing money I don't
watch Supernatural movies involving
spirits on that level what can a human
physically do against a spiritual entity
pray my brother pray
um
I know sometimes movies scare you
uh it scared the hell out of my wife too
because I thought she thought we was
going to go see Super Mario
and we was in there and I was like let's
go
and yeah and the devil popped up boom Oh
my God right so she showed her she is
terrified to hold the whole movie I
couldn't leave him in the house by
herself
she's like don't you leave me down here
don't you leave me down here for the
whole night
it was a good movie
um you got to watch the movie to see
what happens what what what what you
could do against it it's a good movie
Russell Crowe is
um
a fine fine actor he has acting chopped
that's crazy
I fully agree Damon was a massive amount
yeah he has he has range imagine
thinking you're going to go watch Mario
and get a beta switch into some demonic
possession movie on God it was the
funniest thing in the world
on God is the funniest thing it was my
best it's it was one of my best pranks
because she thought we watching trailers
and it was like Sony films blah blah
blah and it's coming in and it started
and she was like oh yeah oh this is that
movie with the priests and exes who is
scary she's like oh this trailer long as
hell
got him
and think about it I was going to see
nefarious out of the movies I gotta find
it in some movie theater me and I got
that Regal app I do the Regal thing yeah
and we go to see movies I gotta see it
because of the show so give people mad
content
but imagine me being I I'm definitely
gonna pull her into this imagine me
being in the movies by myself half the
time it ain't nobody in the movie
theater and I'm watching a possession
movie God forbid something happened to
the king oh you gonna see my Crocs run
out the movie theater and I'm still in
there like oh no help me help me Lord
please
no I had to get her I had to sneak her
in there
so she's gonna watch this your man look
like a whole plum he dressed in a whole
plum suit look like a whole plump oh
Plum is the color of the night
we're gonna Plum up tonight
[Music]
we said
why have you said hit that like button
59 59 let me see let me see eight more
to reach a hundred and Chad let's go
let's spread the link that's right let's
spread that link let's get it
what was that my drink should be making
no noise wait a second oh sound is on
hell no
hold on let me tell Saab
now that's uh the watch them call it the
the stream and the Xbox I gotta make
sure I didn't double pay because it was
a moment that I had went through my
PayPal and then I went through the Xbox
or something crazy some some sick stuff
I'll send it to you
it was crazy
um let me see
thoughts on
um and yes in doing Fulton delay
I was looking so forward to that fight
but I think they had to move that fight
out because everything is crammed
together people only got but so much
money so this month you have this fight
that's a mandatory people's gonna watch
my father called me and said uh do you
think I should get the fight
I said uh if you're gonna ask me you
know you just need that extra Push To Go
Get It Go Get It This is Gonna you're
gonna be happy with this
and
I wanted to see uh Fulton versus uh
anyway
I think that that'll be later on they
should push that one into the fall
right it should be into the fall it
should be there
you hop into Dead Island 2 yet
um attic did the review on it if it's
not a game pass it's not on me pause
um but I don't know maybe I might but I
played it when we went to Pax
very tight game Graphics is incredible
game looks great
dope dope dope game so
um is it something that I will try
probably so at some point in time
King if if if King wears a PlayStation
chain I know he's possessed on God and
them on God and them yeah man because
you know what it is y'all know what it
is y'all know who we rock with we don't
rock with the mother dudes you know what
it is
let me see
put my baby mama on King's Day at King's
Dallas 100 percent
King what's happening not right now they
talking about
um
uh whatchamacola what's this dude um
Andre Ward they're talking about Andre
Ward and his rise to the ring they're
doing a documentary probably on them
right now um Andre Ward this is one of
the fighters that uh my father and I
um
bonded over
his fighting style
his uh versatility in the ring his
ability to take on all challenges and
all and and defeat everybody to get into
that uh middleweight tournament
and to come out on top I I picked him
for the middleweight tournament to win
everybody thought I was crazy when I
said it uh I thought his style and and
it's called SOG the book award which is
crazy
um I thought he was he was Head and
Shoulders above all his peers and he and
he showed it and and in in this day and
age to hell with your oh
you got to be able to have the
willingness to go out there and lose
that old to in order to win immortality
it's about immortality right it's about
after you've done who remembers your
name
Ryan Garcia and tank Davis is going out
here for people to remember their name
we're going to remember this fight we
all going to be talking about where we
was at when we saw this fight
this is the fight that we asked for so
this is what you go for this is how you
chase Glory that that that crowd is
indicative
of these young men going chasing Glory
not sitting there holding no belts not
holding a old not taking No risk
both these dudes is putting it all on
the line
yup fight one hour early
here we go people
he said interest is gonna take out
that's right John definitely you got 93
please share it out let me let me shoot
this link to the chat let me I got I got
a chat that I can shoot the link to let
me see if those people uh follow and
want to get down with the King let's
let's see if that's a thing let's see if
that's a thing you like the graphics the
thumbnail the thumbnail was crazy right
shout out to attic for doing the
thumbnail shout out to attic for for
saving me
um
I'm gonna tell you man uh attic does
the the best man
one of the the best dudes in the world
man I love him to death
you know anytime I have a problem
your boy goes out there and he saves me
man always
I love him to death
okay um
hit that in that group let's see if we
can get seven
let's see if we can get uh six let's see
if we can get him
we can get that 100 we can bust that
Hondo let's show these people what we're
doing
we may not got a thousand watches but we
got 100 strong give me a hundred men
strong to go tear down these walls and
we'll win
there we go let's get it come on y'all
95. see I like that I like that push-up
on each other I like that never back
down I love that man I love that
they even getting it right to it that's
right attic a good dude this week the
undercard Miss had a chance to make my
10 year old a fan he tried to like
that's what's up MMA changed the
perception of the old Fighters had to
come back from losses and elevating
Heights I mean look at style Bender
yo
the thing with the with with MMA
what changed the fight is there's only
one promoter there's only one Banner
there's only one person controlling
everything let's give it to Dana White
and the people behind them right
they control everything
this is not the this is yeah my wife
when they're screaming yo this is this
is not like boxing where everybody is
separate entities all over and then you
have uh sanctioning bodies pulling
people all over the place
right
over here the o means more the
perception wise
than it does in MMA mmma you're going to
get a fight because the promoter deems
it that way so your old and your one
means nothing it's just your last fight
and can we promote you from that
yeah he's walking in on some old
pray please God help me here
yo yo George Foreman 2 said he coming
out to that fufu
where's the link
I shed it out
I was on my Twitter
everybody get that
I'm not gonna lie I don't I don't care
how how Christian I am
on that walkout I need the hardest moves
gangster thuggish songs I need 50 Cent
I'll whip your head boy
I need 50 Cent In My Hood yeah if it
ain't if if it ain't about putting down
putting somebody in the dirt I don't
want hair man he came into I gotta come
on with that that's on me baby
now you can see these if you wanna I
don't need that man if I don't have that
yellow Beezy going into that man you
crazy I need I need Wheezy I need Second
To None I need come on man
I can't have this uh this this soft talk
radio I can't have that he think he
moved nice with his feet you think he's
moving nice to his feet his hands tough
though that boy hands tough though I
like that someone's going to sleep in
the ring tonight
it's starting he's coming out to that
food for whistling son got on the Amari
road yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's nice
yeah it's cold
this is cold
can it be a blanket after you gotta get
picked up though
do they got a blanket for you baby
oh man somebody look bone dry
he looked he looked bone dry bone dry
don't look good pulse listen as a
fighter you want to come out wet you
want to come out soaking wet you want to
come out like somebody through like you
like you ran through a hurricane you
want to come out that way because I know
in the background you warmed up and you
was ready
you trying to sleep tank with that song
it's like can't even listening to that
song taking the background listening to
some some
[Laughter]
on King David he trying to slide through
on you he tried to catch you up
he listening to some real factual oh man
put him in the dirt it's about to be her
time boy
um
he trying to sleep tank with that song
on God I'm nervous for Ryan because it's
like look at his eyes I want him to win
I I want him I want him to get warmed up
I want to get warmed up and if that
punch heats up his face well if he gotta
get heated by the punch let him get
heated by the punch Ryan came to out to
the Titanic soundtrack part two love so
such a tank winning this jump yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah Sosa tank with them Hulk
Colors oh God he about to do it let's
get it
yeah Green on oh
what are you coming through
Sosa
let's go he do got on that purple and he
wants some incredible bloggers
and he got away he got yeah
hey let's go
foreign
who you messing with he coming out with
Chief Keef boy
one of the last o'black hitters
boy Hulk smash he got the Hulk smash
face
you know I'm guarding them boy you know
who I gotta roll with baby come on man
Davis looking to focus as hell yeah
yeah
oh man baby
slide up on your brush your heart out
your chest um
GTD
uh-huh
oh
yo I'm getting Goosebumps and I'm not
even fighting you're right I'm nervous
butterfly in my stomach and I'm not even
fighting
we got a hundred we bust a hundred
yo Turtle everybody
got 100 watch and I love you to death
God bless man
every day don't ever give up you keep
trying you keep pushing I remember when
it was only four people in here with
your rocking with the kid
keep pushing keep trying I'm gonna push
for y'all y'all push for me I'm gonna
push for y'all God bless
let's go
your man in the suit is the money man
you saw on the side he cashed the checks
[Laughter]
look yo the phone checks is guys check
this cashier he in the ring checks his
cash checks his cash let me see what's
that
hit the like button share it out let's
go let's go for sure let's go share that
out share that out we bust a hundred
y'all we bust a hundred y'all that's
what I'm talking about we bust a hundred
y'all I'm proud as hell we bust a
hundred y'all I'm proud as hell
yo
I don't ever dream that 100 people want
to hang out with me
thank you all right so 100 people do
want to hang out yeah yeah this is true
but I'm but I'm saying though I'm saying
that come on come on
five five versus five eight oh man Ron's
a big boy and he's younger too
three ends that's right you know what's
crazy I feel like those three years is
gonna hurt Ryan a lot those three years
are gonna hurt Ryan I think youth is
youth is youth is the key I mean listen
I feel like nah you know why look I I
don't know maybe it's me right as you
age I feel like your body gets more
solid yeah this is true you coming to
your man strength exactly but I'ma tell
you this
I'm gonna tell you this and this is the
honest of God truth this is a young
man's sport it is right so youth is on
his side he will recover faster he would
do things a whole lot faster I know
they're close in age but it's how you
live those 28 years compared to how you
live those 24 years here we go that's
why I'm biased towards Ryan Ryan is a
very clean fighter he's very he's very
uh precise he's very what's what's the
word um uh consistent is he is this is
the same dude that had the mental
breakdown and pulled out a couple of
fights
I eat the oath meal
ideas
can't give him a pass on that what I'm
gonna tell you this is
candy take that punch that's all I'm
here to see
if we're gonna we're gonna get if we
gonna have a fight we got 121 watching
y'all blowing my mind
thank you thank you for sharing that out
you're blowing my mind right now thank
you
we did this man we said we was going to
get here we was gonna get to this fight
and they here now all we need is Earl
Spencer but but signed that contract boy
stop running
Bud stop running bud
get Duck Butt
here we go now he's looking good you saw
that he gave that wink now he's getting
comfortable the lights is down now he's
getting comfortable now it's just him
and Davis yeah look at him yeah
there we go there we go
this is what I
um I like that moment
which is YouTube
It's like a horse race when that when
that tunnel juice This Is Us now like we
here yeah that's It Ain't Nothing Gonna
Stop This Nothing Gonna Stop nothing man
we here one of us gotta fold yeah man
I'm trying to break your way I'll tell
you it's nothing sweeter than making
another man submit pause respectful
[Music]
how do you feel about that who you sound
like who you sound like
absolutely when you raise your kids
right
Davis look like he about been they both
look like they're about business oh God
they both look like they're ready for
business man they both look very serious
Yeah man they both look like they know
the gravity of the situation
what king say grown man business you
gotta be on your grown man business
[Laughter]
yeah yeah yeah hit that bathroom hit the
head
you're dead
Ryan brother's there
family is there
looking good
23 and oh and 19 Knockouts good knockout
ratio that means that he is a boxer
puncher
oh Jason with this the Eight dollar
Super Chat somebody oh must go Boys on
God and them somebody gotta give up that
o it gotta happen man
unless it's a draw
what do you think about that now
anything can go in boxing we ain't think
about that now a draw oh wait
Ryan brother out here looking like a
Mexican Slim Shady on God you're funny
you're funny as hell
this won't be a draw I hear that I mean
it sound good
I don't know boxing I don't know if if
if it's gonna be a draw or not but what
I do know is
somebody about to get this work
I know that somebody somebody present 28
and over 26 Knockouts oh God that's a
scary ass record that is a terrible
that's a scary record we're thinking six
Knockouts out of 28 fights yo think
about it Pitbull he just put out yeah
pit bull cruise is one dude that made it
to the bell and he broke his hand in a
pit bull fight on top of pit bull head
boy
everything changed though my boy My Boy
Floyd hot right now oh okay there will
be a KO King who I got I told you the
prediction uh tank 10th round TKO the
fight the corner gonna stop the fight
probably be a couple of body shots
that's gonna bring Ryan to his knees
he's gonna get up and get hit with it on
on top of the head they're gonna go down
and then his Corner gun throw in the
towel stop that stop that from happening
you think that's a towel you think this
is one of those I think I think it's
going to save them
I think it's going to save him I think
his daughter screams his mom's yells
don't bring your family imma hurt you
all right that's crazy that's crazy it's
all now fight time here we go
here we go
tank looking swollen he looking swollen
look they touch gloves man that's love
and respect
all right round one Let's Get It On
Everything let's go
oh look at that place is back checks is
good
oh it's going turn they go turn up
we're gonna f up tonight
yeah I love this he only had a
mouthpiece looking like Muhammad
suspect dude
you better channel in all that's great
okay
all right Ryan comes out starts jabbing
tank doesn't Rush across the ring Ryan
is jabbing sliding his back foot in with
the jab he drops his left hand
uh he drops his right hand when he's
when he throws the jab and he's and he
and he dips down low
now it could be a setup for the overhand
right tank is trying to measure Ryan's
uh speed and distance Ryan is doing the
pursuing at the moment take his doing
the backing up Ryan is sticking out Jabs
tank is close to the ropes he's pivoting
back and forth Ryan is stalking trying
to cut off the ring Ryan is not putting
his lead foot outside of Tanks foot so
take is able to slip in and out and he's
not cutting off the ring effectively so
right now Ryan is trying to gauge
distance on tank tank is just you know
fainting putting on his hands making
Ryan probably use more than what he
wants to use to close distance Ryan
lands a left hook under the body and
then throws a jab over the top
uh the left hook was uh under the rib
cage of the jab hand
you know remember
um
tank is a southpaw Ryan is orthodox all
right so both lead feet they would step
on each other they would be there right
there the distance is closed
um
right speak up louder so they could hear
you the pivot the pivot is going to be
in the same direction for the most part
since they both opposite saw Fighters
yep
so then so when they duck they're gonna
duck into trouble yeah yeah all right
so
right now remember I told you
tank starts off slow Ryan starts off
slow but the thing is Ryan is the taller
fighter that he has the jab and he has
the the height Advantage so he's able to
control distance right and and the
perception right now is Ryan is
dictating the pace but tank is now
starting to creep across the ring and
starting to touch uh Ryan's jab keeping
his jab hand busy because if he if his
jab hand is busy he can't concentrate on
throwing a hook see what tank is doing
is throwing faints and trying to get to
Ryan's body Ryan throws a jab and throws
a left hook over the top catches tank
and it does nothing but it was a check
left hook just to check and see if he
can touch tank it's still in the center
of the ring on the draftking sign just
moving around just touching it looks
like a sparring session to be honest
with you in the first round but no this
is high speed chess they're setting each
other up they know both know that one
punch can change how you do it tank went
straight to Ryan's body and Ryan you
know slid back nice and good tank wants
to see how Ryan handles movement and
Ryan wants to see how tank handles the
jab rounds over I give that round uh a f
but um if I had to score that round I
would give that round to Ryan
yeah a little more punches landed more
punches
I can see I did see that little scary
little scary body maneuver that uh Davis
just pulled that that would hurt yeah a
lot yeah but it's you know tank what
tank does is when he's able to get you
comfortable with him being in your
circumference
Ryan is long and stiff pause man you
have to put pause after that man come on
man fill out round yeah yeah yeah
nice
15. hey your mom's back there right
yeah Collins what's good
just filling them out that's right slim
all right I'm back at it again
oh my God back at it again
all right so Ryan immediately comes out
throws a jab tank immediately comes out
and backs up he's trying to time uh
Garcia so he's now he's trying to slip
under you see the hand he's trying to
hold his freeze his jab hand and slip on
the
Ryan throws a jab
and
tank slips over
right now Ryan is okay Ryan is attacking
Ryan win at tank and he's throwing
punches and he's going for broke Ryan is
upset for Ryan wants to fight to start
Ryan landed a couple of right hands on
top of tank head Ryan is going for him
Ryan is throwing all the punches tank is
holding Ryan is swinging on him Ryan is
sweet yeah Ryan is swinging on him yeah
Ryan is swinging on him fighting right
so Ryan is Ryan is on the attack Ryan is
throwing blows at tank tank is moving
like a rabbit left to right Ryan is
going right back Ryan is doing heavy
stalking Ryan is throwing the jab right
hand left hook
he's going at him he's going at him tank
grabs tank hole Ryan is pushing
yeah
he's getting a warning your tank stop
holding
right
Ryan is throwing their hands
Ryan wants to fight Ryan wants to fight
yeah Ryan is stalking him Ryan throwing
the Jabs watch the feet watch my boy
feet though yeah he gonna cross his feet
up watch him cross him up he gonna get
him so committed to coming in he gonna
catch him with the uh bang Ryan is
throwing right hand oh that right hand
over the top is crazy oh oh uppercut oh
he buckled tank legs with that uppercut
he buckled tank legs at that uppercut
though that was a good one left hook oh
Ryan Mr left hooky keep missing he tried
to go under oh I dropped him what I told
you time and beat speed all day his legs
ain't right goonie Goku let's go Goldie
Google let's go let's go 48 minutes your
body don't feel right your legs ain't
smelling right Gooney Google the ghoul's
in the building let's get it oh black
here let's go
what I told you he was doing all that
with all that posturing that go ahead
swing crazy again see if you don't get
your knock your block knocked off look
at him uh-huh oh nothing's showing that
right here oh let's go he tried to do
that left hook it ain't work that right
hand is going to come over the top oh
tank looking sweet right there there it
is this is what I'm talking about this
is what the money's about I don't want
him to get that super chat right now
yeah
yeah now tank is up now take us up go
figure that out in the corner I pick
Ryan to win the fight salute King two
dollar Super Chat from hold on one
second let me get you hold on let me get
you Lloyd Metroid you could you could
hey
Lord Metroid you super chatted you can
go back
you can take that super chat back and
you can say King
I think I'm gonna have to go with tank
[Laughter]
oh his body said oh my God what was that
who what hit me me I hit you
that was that was a that was that was
that was on punch
Boop timing I timed you boy
that's what I told you man but I told
you you're gonna be in this
circumference he did the same thing two
times yes like it was bound for the
third there you go oh
how you doing it made you disappear say
it louder
say it louder where you at
ah where you at my body I can't feel my
body my legs don't work where you at
ah
let's get it all right round three
here we go there we go there we go tank
is up now going into round three
because remember that's a two-point
round so he wins that round and if Ryan
won the first round then uh tank
effectively goes up around
um
think about it this way
if what if somebody scored the first
round for tank tank is up to three
rounds of nothing
no no don't happen
all right so Ryan right now is back you
got to respect Ryan Ryan stays in
stalking mode
right and he's throwing his jab he's
been he's listening he's being mindful
he's listening he's throwing the jab he
has his hand up he knows that right hand
is there so he you understand that tank
can drop you with with his left yeah
that left can drop you but that's not
Tank's power hand his power hand it's
his right hand his lead hand that's the
hand that he's gonna put the work in I
just want to see when tank gets in so
right now Ryan has high guard he went
into high guard and he's jabbing off the
high God High guard is here he's jabbing
over here take one over the top trying
to catch him with the left hand all
right so tank is trying to show him his
hand speed I still think Ryan has better
hand speed he's longer he has better
hand speed and he's younger right it's
Ryan hops back when he hops back tanks
is out of distance so what tank would
need to do is to get Ryan up against the
Rope stand Ascent to the ring and right
now tank is uh jabbing and sliding under
Ryan's guard Ryan is keeping his right
hand glued to the side of his face
because he's he's fearful of uh tanks uh
left hand that actually penetrated his
guard that dropped him all right so I
mean his natural reaction but Ryan is is
not gun shy he went right back to the
fight all right you're in a fight anyway
so what's gonna happen you know it is
what it is so you got to do what you got
to do all right so tank is on him yeah
because uh you know he that's just a
flash knockdown I told you he's young
he's gonna recover quick all right now
tank is uh systematically starting to
break Ryan down right now Ryan is going
to the left hook they've trained for
Ryan's left hook the whole fight right
the whole training camp has been
training for Ryan's left hook that's the
fight the punch that they talked about I
want to see the counter that's going to
come off of that right there right so we
got to continue to watch what happens
with that we have a 19 seconds left in
the third round and tank is measuring
Ryan Ryan is allowing tank to put his
hand on the guard all right see tank is
timing him now you saw that time of the
right hand right
see there you go we got three seconds
left
tank tank right now is having fun all
right uh Hollywood rules into two dollar
Super Chat laughing my butt off Gooney
Google never changed my brother oh God
thank you baby
yeah look at Mike right there Mike
loving this Mike loving this he said all
Praises dude this is what I talked about
young dudes getting it in all right Dan
Goose into the common air right there in
this corner I think he needed Dan goose
in this at this point in his life Oscar
went through many trainers I think Floyd
father was um uh like Floyd or
Mayweather senior is uh probably was
Oscar's best trainer no disrespect for
his early trainers but uh he he taught
Floyd I mean taught Oscar defense right
so Oscar after that became a complete
fighter
right now they keep telling tank to
faint him fade him out of socks and then
um time them his whole corner is telling
him to time him
Floyd must have yelled something where's
his mouthpiece
his mouthpiece is it
yeah all right so we right back at it
again round number four right now I give
tank up
um
yeah I don't know
it's kind of crazy
look look right now all right so right
now tank is doing a a move when you tuck
your your gloves up and you come in and
you weave under right yeah all right so
what Garcia is doing is to how to get
him out of that is you check his body
Garcia is throwing left to Tank's body
right they're all in the center of the
Ring right now guys
um and again this this
fainting and there's posturing going on
in the middle of the ring this is high
speed chase chest right here all right
so we got Ryan again fainting with the
jab and um showing the right hand but
he's not tossing the right hand he
tossed the right hand at the end of the
third round but not the beginning of the
fourth round I don't know why is that
right you have to do something other
than that jab all right he double
fainted and threw a jab to Tank's body
tank double fainted throws a right hand
I mean throws a left hand to Ryan's body
he throws a left hand to Ryan's body
again I think the idea is if he could
touch him with the body shot
um Ryan throws a right hand to Tank's
Chin Chang tank laughs and throw a right
to uh Ryan's body all right so now we
notice that tank anytime he wants he can
get in and close distance and what
whatchamacola Ryan is doing is trying to
time him with that left hook coming in
remember this is going to be a timing
fight I think faints uh plays a big part
uh the Jabs right hand the right hands
to the body from tank I think tank is uh
definitely uh picked up his pace
and he's touching Ryan's body more than
Ryan wants him to touch the body
um because if he could take the speed
away from Ryan as far as the speed in
his legs and gets Ryan's mouth open
which Ryan mouth is starting to open now
uh how much road work did Ryan do that
starts to come into play see now he
timed him again and tried to catch him
with the same right hand Ryan is
susceptible to that right hand from a
South Pole and I'm noticing it more and
more because I told you before he drops
his right hand when he Jabs so he opens
his chin up
and I told you that early on that I saw
that flaw in his game when they told him
to switch his jab up he had a perfect
job before I don't know why whoever told
him to switch that job up
so you did go tank tank is trying to
slide in tank wants to get that work he
wants the Reckless Ryan from round
number two
he wants that Ryan that Ryan right there
Then patient Ryan
's over I thought it was enough work in
there
um giving it to tank
um
see that that hand you see that hand
that right hand off his eye and and Ryan
knows Ryan knows
yeah he popped that nose he's starting
to bleed him out
Garcia is being too cautious allowing
take to dictate the fight laugh out loud
better Lord Metro
that was an impressive left hook yes sir
Canelo probably learned Canelo probably
learned from Canelo since they both cool
with each other
um you mean uh Ryan probably learned
from Canelo since they both cool with
each other we have 156 watching that's a
new height that's a new height God bless
all Praises do
Floyd right there the money man in the
building
there we go
all right
so we are in round number five where if
if you're scoring a fight you probably
got tank winning
you probably got tank winning if you're
scoring the fight
we almost got 160 watching
God is a wonderful thing
good job
Ryan Ryan I gotta I Gotta Give Ryan
respects because Ryan has been pushing
the fight you know not saying that he's
using effective ring generalship I'm
just saying that he's pushing the fight
as far as stepping forward all right and
I'm not saying that tank isn't accepting
but again as the biggest uh total
fighter he what he should have been
doing was letting both hands fly
he's he's he's holding his right hand go
yeah not because that's the hand that
that's where he get punched at yeah
that's where you get punched at so you
gotta send them bro but this is why you
see that right hand that's why he don't
send it when he Jabs he drops the right
hand that's something that you can train
for that's something that you can time
and and camp and Garcia
uh he needs to keep that hand up and go
in there like a one-arm machine like the
one-on Bandit going there throwing hooks
throwing Jabs see when he shoots that
right hand that's what tank wants
because he knows that left hook can't go
he's not hooking right
what I told you somebody that hooks off
their job is a hard person to beat
you got to be able to jab and hook right
off that jab flop and turn it while it's
out Pat turn and step in with your right
hand
he has no confidence in his right hand
and he's he's afraid of the counterpunch
this is what happens when you get
touched up when you get touched with
something you get you get cautious right
right now he's that's this is where he
don't want there you go covered up he
covering up he covering his whole head
he said boy please not in front of my
family please
he covered in his whole head I ain't
never seen no professional boxer dude
yeah he did with that body punch yeah
what I told you though what's going to
be what I told you it was gonna be well
I told you
time for round
all right let's go
see he he let he letting tank get in
there to touch that body up
and if you let tank touch that body yeah
yeah he keep turning he keep covering
that head man he don't want that face
hit uh he doing a salsa dance on him hey
yeah Ryan throw that oh tank he tank
will shoot you with that shot he gonna
shoot that shot there hey he's coming
down the middle boy
slide down slide down all right
slide down yeah
tanking his head he's in his head so so
all right so what what I'm saying right
now is any time that uh tank throws that
uh that left hook that left in Ryan
covers up what the hell is that
he gave him his back he get yeah man you
don't you don't do that man that's crazy
yeah gonna see a better tighten that
body up Garcia Who Wants To Be A YouTube
Star Ryan letting take figure him out
bad mistake I'm glad it's to make it the
combat talk that's what's up JS what's
good no I'm not feeling at all hey man
eating Ross King he said King saving
them eighty dollars what up wolf trying
my best baby trying to give y'all a
fight
trying to give y'all a fight trying to
give y'all to you man that place is
packed out there look beautiful man I
love to see that man boxing is alive and
breathing on you
oh here they go sent to the ring round
number six
there we go I got tank winning the fight
but Ryan ain't far behind Ryan is one
punch away from turning things different
that's what I'm saying he let that right
go he might do something different yeah
but you can't be covering up like that
being scared like that You Gotta Throw
these punches you can't let tank touch
you shoulder to shoulder you cannot do
that
all right especially you got them Hulk
gloves on hit you with that Hawk mid
right in the face plus two damage yeah
yeah right here you got A plus two you
got A plus two Warrior mode
uh why are you throwing that love [__]
from that far out there oh good right
hand oh good right hand oh good right
hand all these right hands is from Ryan
Ryan throws the left hook Ryan throws a
jab tank tank tank bite his teeth say
come on boy
here we go
oh
all right so all right so Ryan uh tank
right now is throwing uh left to the
body what the hell happened all right
they send the bullet they fix this we
back we back at it all right so tank is
throwing uh left to Ryan body
right and and jabbing over the top
remember tank is a southpaw so that
means that he punches with his right
hand as his jab hand right Ryan Garcia
is an orthodox fighter I mean in his jab
is his left hand okay oh my God he
almost caught him if he would if if
Garcia would have threw that right hand
in court tank on his chin yeah yeah
so right now they're fighting so right
now you're in a fight they're in the
center of the Ring though and they they
they they're judging distance tank is
actually moving a whole lot faster now
you can tell the difference between the
two fighters and tanks feet is faster
than Ryan Garcia's feet but Ryan has
fast hands oh good uppercut from tank
that caught Ryan in between the right
hand and he was trying to throw tank is
trying to make him drop his right hand
by punching them to the body so much so
he can come over the top with that that
left you see that's the left that he
wants to land
oh a good combination Ryan through a jab
uppercut and a right that tried to
finish
um tank but they weren't there tank has
underrated defense guys remember I tell
you the best that ever as at defense is
his mentor so tank right now is touching
him and he's mauling them now they
understand to the ring and anytime he
gets close he's going to Ryan's body
he's trying to sap Ryan and take
whatever strength that he has in him so
if he has that nervous energy he's
trying to pull that nervous energy out
of him dancing now round is over that
round can go either way Garcia look good
be more all day be more baby big men
King what up Thomas great oh
shout out to my man Thomas Lee Grady
what's good baby oh right hand
over the top right hand because
look he's stepping back he steps back he
steps back but he's he's jabbing out
he's jabbing out and every time he puts
his leg back he he's open to just but
you know why
exactly it's like bro you gotta you
gotta risk it you gotta risk it
they go to Charlo Brothers the Charlo
Brothers is in the house demons
fresh and Jamal bet 10 000 or 15 000 on
Ryan about the same room it's crazy yeah
that's that's what I say crazy that's
what I say it's kind of nuts yeah
what they have been as children just two
pit bulls dope ass kids crazy you want
that that's fine round number seven
said check his glove
yeah check his glove we don't trust him
Gabe AKA Carolina 16. oh we appreciate
you King thank you you just three pieced
uh he got a tank with three punches yes
tank was in the corner Ryan went at him
Ryan tank didn't look good pulling up
his pants right there he and his legs
look wobbly right there
no no he just caught a flush
okay
oh
right hand
by Tank
um Ryan throws a left he's waking up
right now we waking up
yeah they definitely got Davis up on the
scoreboard yeah
but we don't go by that of course
nice job by by Garcia
he's stalking him he's keeping his hands
close he goes into peekaboo now now he's
going into peekaboo and he's staying
close to tank knowing that you know he
has power too so he he got to be willing
to to force that power tank Jabs him
through his guard uh well shoots the the
left who's gone one two punches that he
goes that tank tank covers up dips out
and pivots right back at him all right
and they back in the center to the ring
all right so here we go oh uppercut by
tank now tank is stalking him Ryan takes
a knee to the body he dropped Ryan again
I told you the heart will come into play
oh
he quit and the fight is over he got hit
with that shot the boy ain't want no
more
shout out to tank what I told you what I
told you what I told you
what I told you
boy you ain't want no more that shot
they'll that shot was well that shot was
something coming up to the next shot
he ain't want no more that
he want no more shout out to the 160
that's watching on guarding them we
doing this together
yo bud I hope you watch him you next bud
big mouths get their mouths closed
he told you don't bring your kids to
this fight he told you tell your mama
stay home what the [__] was that body
shot I don't I don't know he looked like
he hit him in the face I'm gonna tell
you right now if Ryan Garcia says I
couldn't see if he tell if he tell you
this dude hit me and I can't see we
gonna start we're gonna start calling
tank the lights out man he shut your
album he's a ophthalmologist he turns
your eyeballs off
your man going there KMC
yo Ryan said no Moss I'm
gonna show that shot
show the shot we was just getting into
it this fold out was outrageous to me
like the fold out was crazy thank you
Lord Metroid yo thank you man I am
considered lucky that anybody Rock
excuse me I was rocking out with me
anybody's here
I appreciate each and every last one
more than anything I appreciate my son
being here and we able to you know to
chop it up with boxing and he he's able
to see the knowledge that I have and
what I say is prophetic and what it say
is true and that uh Ryan was not gonna
win tonight
laughs
that's crazy yeah boy
what up what a big cloud
show that shot man
show that shot we knew he was ready here
we go here we go here we go here we go
here's the shot oh it's the body shot
yeah yeah he made him doodoo on himself
he did poo poo he poo poo on himself he
said oh man hell no oh God this is he
about to kill me referee stop the fight
he said referee please he took his
window away
I told you he kept going to his body
he got into the first real test this is
first real test he touched that body he
said oh man I'm going back on Instagram
[Laughter]
yeah look at his Rib was nice and good
he said how you doing how you doing let
me push off right here let me get that
let me get that touch her under the
titty
he took his nipple he got his nipples he
got your nipple so man oh [__] what the
hell is that
yeah
oh no no no wait a second here help me
please please please I'm too handsome
for this this guy's Savage where he from
he brought oh he brought Sosa so sad
yo
oh the moment though that's good because
I'm telling you he watches it he fights
with his eyes open he been trying to get
that body for a minute
that body shot was nasty yeah the fight
is done already Jim crying yes sir gotta
hurry take Shin well yeah let me tell
you
Tank's chin is a plus he got hit with
some shots man
Tank's chin is a plus
a plus you we're talking about a A plus
Fighter fighting another a plus fighter
and making that a plus fighter say no
mas
I don't want none of this
listen I don't know what happens after
this right I thought if you go out on
your Shield
you get around you get a second fight
how do you get a second fight yeah it
was in the seventh
he said Ryan still got more followers
yeah Hulk smash definitely on God y'all
know how I do
y'all know how I do hawks definitely
smashed it look at his mama there in a
t-shirt she ain't coming no Versace
ain't trying to look off now we come
here for war
my baby coming to take your baby out
what she got an icy white she got a five
dollar special she got the icy White
oh man I thought you said two wrongs
right
I see this is a different thing
man don't don't don't don't talk about
it be about it that's what I was
thinking who who won I just got off tank
one
honey and Loma give yo listen
What God Says The Proven cornball now
listen
oh no I just I just wanted to see if
Garcia could take tank shots
and obviously he couldn't he started
covering up that covering up thing
showed me a lot right a lot right there
now right second round yeah
he got he it's true it's true experience
and you got a lot more yeah I told you I
I like I told my son he got a lot
he has to fight people he has to fight
so now now fighting those tomato cans
did that do anything
now what I told you I told you time and
beat speed all day what he did he timed
the hell out of him definitely
definitely I didn't count for the time
now but see but other fights was
indicative of that when he fought rolly
impeccable timing roly had more power on
him roley was closing in he timed him
all the fights that tank has been having
he's been winning all the time and who
taught him time and Floyd Pacquiao way
faster than Floyd
what beat Pacquiao timing
did not expect it to be over this early
but God and them man we did this thing
man we did we we bust a buck 60. I love
each and every last one of you thank you
so much I appreciate everybody for
coming out and um I want y'all to look
at this outro uh with um biographic God
and and Daz uh Dallas
sorry
check it out
[Music]
fights out can't hit a thing when it
lights off can't talk
can't talk heavy with a light Joe my
wind might lose or my draw
cause I'm spitting them swinging fire
talking pickled peppers make them pay
the piper cause I might go live like a
rude discussion and deflate your chest
like a food production you'll be talking
like you want a new concussion a dude a
custom attitude adjustment these are
fighting words better give me that
respect that I deserve for another
Redemption
[Music]